[Musique]
alors bonjour à tous je m'appelle nazim
et il ya de grandes chances que vous ne
connaissez pas mais peut-être que vous
connaissez certains des artistes pour
lesquels j'ai eu la chance de faire des
chansons par exemple kenji avenir
florent pagny claudio capéo au chili ou
black m
et donc qui sont pour certains des
interprètes ou pour certains des gens
avec qui je collabore pour faire des
chansons
je vais essayer de scinder un petit peu
mon mon petit haut quand deux parties en
vous expliquant comment on arrive à
faire ce métier qui n'est pas vraiment
un métier celui d'auteur compositeur et
ensuite par quel processus créatif on
arrive à faire naître des chansons qui
pourront dans le meilleur des cas aller
jusqu'à vous aurez tout a commencé par
une livraison de pizzas donc j'étais
voilages était livreur est étudiant à la
fac je m'en sortais assez mal je dois
dire mais parce que je travaillais pas
beaucoup il ya souvent cette idée reçue
un peu que les artistes travaillent pas
parce que c'est vrai que souvent on a
l'impression de pas travailler nous
mêmes j'ai entendu par exemple gus qui
parlait de ça et qui se considéraient
comme quelqu'un qui travaille peut alors
que je pense qu'ils travaillent
énormément et c'est notre cas à tous
sauf qu'on travaille en fait selon son
nom des règles qui ne sont un peu
propres dans mon cas par exemple je suis
autodidacte à l'instrument et donc j'ai
pas fait un conservatoire de guitare ou
et très tardivement j'ai pris un peu de
cours de piano
sauf qu'en fait on a tous regardé dans
le faire dans mon cas des dizaines de
vidéos sur youtube on s'est saigné les
doigts sur un instrument donc finalement
on a beaucoup travaillé sur le savoir et
et en parlant d' inspiration il ya cette
phrase de picasso ce sera ma seule
citation que j'aime bien
qui dit que l'inspiration existe mais un
mec on la rencontre en travaillant et
donc j'ai fait des petits casting sur
internet
et de fil en aiguille je me suis
retrouvé à l'olympia pour une finale
d'un casting où on m'a dit ok tu dois
chanter
florent pagny c'est aux antipodes de ma
vie j'ai un peu paniqué et on m'a dit ok
tu es trop jeune
c'est pas ton truc tu seras donc pas
interprète sauf que de cet échec est de
ceux qui vont suivre dont je vous
parlais
henné un petit peu l'envi justement de
faire des chansons pour d'autres
artistes j'ai eu l'occasion de la bad
croiser des artistes qui n'était pas
forcément connus et qui donc m'ont
laissé un petit peu on laissait un peu
la chance de pouvoir bosser avec eux ça
n'a rien donné
si ce n'est qu' il ya une artiste je
vais la cité elle s'appelle melissa
nkonda qui s'est dit elle a gagné ce
fameux casting en fait à la gale a gagné
ce concours là et donc elle a gagné un
album chez universal music et elle
soulève tout le monde en leur disant bon
nazis nazis mais super faut vous le
rencontriez faut que vous le rencontriez
est en fait il se trouve que il ya eu un
coup de coeur réciproque avec une
directrice artistique la bac qui
s'appelle michel demi et qui m'a dit ok
on te saigner
ça m'a permis de mettre un petit pied
mettre un petit pied dans le métier et
donc bah j'avais tous mes petits rêves
comme ça ok quand est ce que j'écris
pour johnny quand est-ce que je compose
pour bruno mars et c est rien de tout ça
évidemment de s'est passé j'ai eu la
chance de faire une deuxième fois
l'olympia c'est pour un artiste inconnu
c'était pas mal et c'était pour le coup
une forme de tremplin comme ça où il est
c'est un peu les artistes qui étaient
signées par ce qu'on appelle en édition
c'est à dire qu'on est signant l'auteur
compositeur et en fait j'ai eu la chance
de
de faire une prestation qui a plu et on
m'a proposé un contrat d'artiste donc là
c'est pour être aussi interprète et en
l'occurrence dans mon cas l'interprète
de mes propres chansons
donc j'étais super content j'ai doublé
ma petite avance par deux du coup
puisque j'ai signé un contrat d'artiste
je me suis retrouvé à me dire ok dans le
trois mois c'est bon c'est le succès
qu'est-ce qui se passe sauf qu'on m'a
dit ah toi tu attends ils ont commencé à
remettre plein de choses en question et
c'est le parcours d'un artiste aussi
c'est pas ta bille et tu sais pas parler
tu parles encore un petit peu comme
comme un garçon des quartiers tes
chansons on n'est pas sûr en fait
finalement et c'est vrai que j'ai perdu
confiance dans nos projets d'artistes
énormément et d'ailleurs qui n'est à ce
jour jamais sorti vraiment et j'ai eu
une petite période de ok qu'est ce que
je vais pouvoir faire parce que
maintenant j'ai 23ans genre c'est un peu
compliquée j'en suis plus trop l'âge de
faire des études et un peu comme une
dernière chance comme ça on dit il ya un
séminaire j'avais même pas ce que
c'était donc vous allez être plein
d'auteurs compositeurs dont il y aura
toi et il ya yannick noah qui passe en
fait on se retrouve tous à ce séminaire
en normandie
il vient je ne sais pas pourquoi
humainement et un truc qui accroche
avant même les chansons et on se
retrouve en fait très vite à ok propose
mois des chansons il me dit on va voir
ce que ce que tu as dans le ventre mais
moi je me dis ok je vais prendre le
contre-pied de ce qui fait d'habitude et
je me dis ok j'ai pas envie de lui faire
des trucs un peu de reggae
africains et tout ça je me dis ok j'ai
lu faire chanson française classique
pour l'une un truc un peu funky pour
l'autre et bref on accroche il accroche
aussi me prend trois chansons dont une
qui prendront single etc
la carrière d'auteur compositeur était
un petit peu lancé 10 et ensuite ma
deuxième forte aux rencontres là-dessus
d'auteur compositeur c'est avec kmg pour
lequel j'ai pu faire en daluz les yeux
de la mama ou d'autres chansons que vous
connaissez peut-être pour arriver au
processus créatif
il n'y a pas de règle encore une fois
mais il ya une discipline quand même
c'est à dire que je pense que on fait un
métier hyper paradoxale où on travaille
jamais et où on travaille tout le temps
où on va capter une idée où on va
s'arrêter pour faire quelque chose ou on
va s'entraîner chez soi mais sans se
rendre compte qu'on s'entraîne ensuite
soit on va avoir fait une chanson dans
l'intimité tout seul qu'on va envoyer un
artiste c'était le cas des premières
chansons de kenji par exemple qui
recevait les chansons où on va aussi
rencontrer un artiste qui lui même a des
velléités de d'auteurs et compositeurs
et on va travailler ensemble c'est assez
difficile parce qu'on a chacun un peu on
a à l'intérieur des esgaulx d'artistes
il faut être curieux il faut être
partageur il faut écouter l'idée en même
temps aller vers sa conviction enfin et
donc ça m'amène au deuxième artiste dont
je voulais parler parce que ça a été une
rencontre un peu justement le de
curiosité qui s'appelle amir qui lui un
jour m'a appelé et m'a dit voilà j'aime
bien ce que tu fais moi je commençais à
avoir une petite carrière d'auteur
compositeur et lui avait fait ce vol
c'est un peu depuis pas mal de mois je
crois et donc c'est un peu retombée
enfin il y avait un peu de tout à tout à
reconstruire tout à construire même au
début pareil je lui proposais beaucoup
les chansons et ensuite la depuis
quelques temps on fait vraiment tout son
répertoire ensemble et et pour illustrer
le processus créatif et je voulais faire
une chanson que que j'ai vu que j'ai eu
la chance de lui proposer qui s'appelle
longtemps bon c'était dit ok on me l a
pas encore sa chanson d'amour france en
parler entre nous c'est dommage enfin
moi je disais c'est dommage pour un mec
aussi beau qui chante hyper bien et tout
de ne pas avoir ta chanson d'amour je
suis parti du postulat suivant je me dis
ok tout le monde dirait
ok je t'aime je suis pas à tuer le
soleil de ma vie est ce qu'on veut et je
lui dis pourquoi pas commencé en faisant
le contraire et donc la chanson a fait
qu'ils s'appellent longtemps elle
commence par je veux des problèmes
attention est pareil un peu plus loin
dans la chanson au lieu au lieu de dire
par exemple je t'aime pour toujours je
voulais dire je t'aime pour longtemps et
voilà c'est on n'a rien inventé de toute
façon en musique c'est très compliqué
d'inventer parce que si on invente trop
en fait on déstabilise les gens et si
tant est qu'on qu'on ait la possibilité
d'inventer un mais il faut donc en fait
être original mais sans être
complètement fou quoi mais bon laissons
parler la musique
[Musique]
je veux des problèmes je veux que tes
gars l'air de rien les miennes je veux
que tu me balance au visage théo
racheter peine pour des nuits
diluviennes
je veux qu'on ça prenne je veux partager
tes joies télégramme.com dans le vertige
et aimant le maine où rien ne nous
gênent
je pourrais même tatoué notre histoire
sur le bras mais dans de beaux draps
cité avec moi c'est toi dans ce monde de
fous je le sais c'est tout et je
voudrais que ça dure longtemps usé main
postulat tient un jour j'oublierai tout
jusqu'à mon nom je saurai simplement que
tu es là que tu es belle que tu es mien
je voudrais que ça dure sentant que
jamais d'un réseau d'athènes cet aveu
cette envie de rêver tous les deux quand
même jusqu'à ce qu'un jour nos deux yeux
c'était que ce que ça illustre c'est que
il ya toujours un cadre dans ce qu'on
fait c'est à dire que là par exemple
là ce sont d accord mais peut-être que
pour vous ce sera un contrat ou une
structure d'entreprise inventoriant tout
et tout existe déjà mais au sein de ce
cadre
conscient ou inconscient voilà il existe
un espace de liberté est très
modestement
voilà c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire et
en plus quand on a la chance de recevoir
aujourd'hui dans ce monde moderne
les retours des gens qui vous disent ben
moi j'ai demandé ma femme en mariage sur
cette chanson ou parfois qu'ils se sont
vraiment à tout et comme dans la chanson
le texte c'est vrai que ça prend aussi
tout son sens et on se dit que cette
galère a servi à quelque chose et je
voulais aussi rebondir sur un truc assez
important qui me vient là les échecs
nous amène toujours ailleurs et c'est
assez banal de dire ça mais sauf que
dans mon cas par exemple j'avais
totalement renoncé à avoir un projet
d'artistes et j'étais heureux avec ça ça
allait pas de problème sauf que de fil
en aiguille en fête les artistes
auxquels je proposais des chansons m'ont
dit ouais mais je chante super bien
viens viens en première partie et c'est
vrai que balla j'ai commencé à
rencontrer un public depuis très peu de
temps
et là c'est plus possible évidemment
mais en tout cas j'ai commencé à
rencontrer un public
il a commencé à se passer des choses et
notamment ça m'a permis de reprendre
confiance
la base de notre métier tellement
fragile si quelqu'un vous dit que ce que
vous faites c'est nul vous pouvez pas le
contredire vous pouvez pas lui dire non
moi je sais non parce que personne ne
sait
et je voulais aussi vous parler d'une
autre chanson que pour le coup vous
connaissez pas c'est vrai que j'aurais
pu en choisir d'autres mais ça va
illustrer un dernier truc très important
je trouve dans ce qu'on fait on fait un
métier de conviction d'abord on est
convaincu soi mais ensuite on doit
convaincre le reste du monde c'est un
peu un jeu un jeu de séduction entre
nous elle reste du monde et on rencontre
un jeune artiste voulais vous parler
d'un artiste avec lequel je travaille et
que je produis aussi qui s'appelle simon
est en fait cet artiste là aujourd'hui
n'est pas connue et le travail qu'on
essaye de faire ensemble c'est de faire
en sorte que que ses chansons son
univers sa gueule ce qu'il a à dire en
fait traverse un peu notre petit cercle
de gens qui aimons le projet pour aller
ailleurs
alors tout ne dépend pas de nous
évidemment malheureusement je veux dire
avant même que cela n'arrive jusqu'au
publié il ya des attachés de presse
il ya des managers peut-être que
certains d'entre vous seront manager ou
patrons de maisons de disques et donc
c'est aussi en fait à chaque fois des
étapes de séduction comme mon travail
c'est de ces décès de convaincre à
travers les chansons que je fais les
gens pour qu'ils soutiennent aussi des
artistes qui n'existait pas avant
j'ai décidé de vous jouer un extrait du
premier single convient de sortir donc
pour simon et qui s'appelle paris
[Musique]
on dit que les snobs on dit d'elle
qu'elle est pressée faut sortir le grand
jeu
si tu espères lembras elle que juge à
ton job approche pas s'ils étaient
stressés la plus élégante
le problème c'est qu'elle le sait des
fois je la déteste j'veux lamoudi jeu la
délaisse je change de décor
quand il pleut dehors je retourne ma
veste
finalement je la donne
bien sûr j'en ai vu d'autres des grandes
des belges la seule qui me fait vibrer
ses terres ses terres c'est tellement
beau que des fois je m'arrête
est ce que c'est un rêve déjà au dessus
du loup images ici avait la mer dis moi
que tu m'aimes paris dis moi que tu
m'aimes tu manques tu est jalouse quand
je te quitte pour le week-end dis moi
que tu m'aimes paris dis moi que tu
m'aimes
ce qui ne t'aime pas l'erreur est
humaine je me sens emporté par la foule
je me sens emportées par la boue
je me sens portée par là
le sens portée par la porte et par là
[Musique]